my name is Tex Murphy I'm a small-time
private investigator in the big city in
new San Francisco my office isn't in the
glamour districts it's in the rundown
mutant part of the city close to Coit
Tower a place they've been refurbishing
for years but it never seems to improve
I've cracked some pretty big cases over
the years we may even hurt me but I
don't do much investigating anymore what
year do you think it is are you serious
whoever did this to you could have wiped
your memory entirely but they didn't I'm
a big fan forgiving and forgetting
mostly forgetting do you have
disturbingly realistic vivid dreams of
another era whatever happened to that
big lovable [ __ ] if I'd asked that two
days ago he would have punched me in the
face
maybe I should punch you now might jog
both our memories yes nice classic its
Murphy I don't know what kind of bastard
I turned it it's one of the great
mysteries
Tesla conducted an experiment it nearly
took out a whole chunk of New York City
man has created hell on earth
the man exists the further he descends
from the wisdom and discernment needed
to overcome the darkness was the big
deal with the Tesla inventions I mean
there must be some reason they were
never made Nikola Tesla was a genius the
FBI
swooped in and confiscated all his
papers in the Tesla cache just disappear
this is what ties a lot in Ted can't
really remember why I became a PI maybe
because I believed in its code of honor
but even a set of principles can slowly
slip from your grasp
temptations become obsessions each day
innocence fades your character weakens
mantis you gotta hold it together yeah
gotta tell me where the egg
[Music]
everything has led to this
[Music]